now if you think it's hot here in las
vegas it's even hotter in death valley
it was 125 degrees ted wasn't it 126.
125. 125. we just wanted to double check
in case it went up in the last hour
still in the 120 degrees believe it or
not
the death valley heat is quite the
tourist attraction for visitors from
around the world
but with international travel
restrictions still in place there are
less visitors abby wines from death
valley national park describes the heat
as literally
walking into an oven somewhere in the
120s is when
i start personally having this weird
effect outside where my forehead goes
numb
that only happens maybe around 123 and
hotter
and you go straight from air
conditioning into the heat it's just
all encompassing that you can't ignore
it it's all around you
a hot warm glove pushing down on you
good explanation there if you're
planning to visit death valley stay on
the main road wrap up your hike or your
sightseeing walks by 10 o'clock in the
morning at the latest
and a little bit of history on death
valley the hottest temperature ever
recorded
134 degrees that happened in july of
1913.